bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat ce matin je vous propose de suivre
les conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire sur le projet de loi création
et internet
les sept députés et sept sénateurs qui
se sont réunis mardi soir on trouver une
position commune sur ce texte
ils ont rétabli ce qu'on appelle déjà la
double peine en cas de téléchargement
illégal
l'internaute verra sa connexion
suspendue et il devra continuer de payer
son abonnement pendant la durée de la
suspension
la commission mixte paritaire est donc
revenu sur le vote des députés qui
avaient décidé à l'unanimité d'exonérer
le paiement de l'abonnement pendant la
durée de la suspension
bonne séance à tous l'ordre du jour
appelle l'examen des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire chargée de
proposer un texte sur les dispositions
restant en discussion du projet de loi
favorisant la diffusion et la protection
de la création sur internet dans la
discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur michel
thiollière rapporteur pour le sénat de
la commission mixte paritaire mon cher
collègue vous avez la parole monsieur
président malade à ministre mais chaque
collègue nous arrivons ce matin au terme
d'un long processus processus de
constatations et processus législatif
qui a commencé par une demande du
président la république de s'occuper du
piratage sur internet
et comme vous savez qui a confié à cette
époque à denis olivennes le soin de
mener des discussions d'une constatation
qui se sont traduits par des accords
sont intervenu le 23 novembre 2007 par
un ensemble de mesures proposées par les
professionnels de la création à la suite
de quoi
madame la ministre vous avez proposé une
loi au parlement
ce projet de loi que je vais présenter
le 18 juin 2007 nous à 2008 nous a
permis ensuite de travailler de procéder
à sa nombre d'auditions et de pouvoir
ici au sénat commençait au 29 les 29 et
30 octobre dernier par une discussion
cette discussion a vu un dépôt de 84
amendements 48 oh non notre commission
des fins culturelles 10 au nom des
affaires économiques et un certain
nombre d'amendements provenant des
différents groupes de notre assemblée à
la suite de quoi l'assemblée nationale a
elle aussi fait son travail et la
commission mixte paritaire s'est réuni
ce 7 avril
je peux dire peut-être ici au nom de
tous mes collègues du sénat puisque nous
avons adopté ce projet de loi à une
quasi-unanimité le 30 octobre dernier
que nous avons travaillé le plus
utilement possible et que nous avons
finalement rempli notre rôle de
l'assemblée parlementaire qui a
travaillé à la fois au fond sur un texte
de loi mais qui a aussi cherché à
répondre à deux problématiques
principales la première s'était
finalement de réconcilier deux mondes le
monde de la création et le monde
d'internet de manière à ce que ces deux
mondes ne s'opposent pas mais au
contraire puissent travailler dans
l'avenir ensemble le plus possible
et puis aussi permettre d'accompagner
une mutation entre une pratique et qui
était celle du piratage répandue vers
une nouvelle pratique qui serait celle
du respect des auteurs et de la création
et celle d'une pratique je républicaine
de l'internaute qui respecte le droit
tout en ayant une grande liberté d'aller
et de venir sur la toile ce texte donc
aujourd'hui après la cmp est un texte
équilibré qui se veut efficace et
pédagogique
je voudrais d'ailleurs dire au passage
que nos collègues l'assemblée nationale
ont apprécié le travail qui avait été
fait ici chez nous pour améliorer autant
que faire se peut ce projet de loi
alors nous avons combattu en cmp je vous
rassure nous avons combattu de façon
très républicaine et très courtoise
et pas du tout par corporatisme
d'assemblée ou patriotisme de chambre
mais tout simplement parce que nous
étions portés par la légitimité d'un
vote qui avait été quasi ici à accepter
une quasi unanimité comme je rappelais
il vient à l'instant
alors pourquoi finalement nous sommes
tous battus avec courtoisie mais avec
vivacité dans cette cmp bien tout
simplement parce que nous sommes
attachés
ici au sénat par tradition et aussi de
façon très régulière à chaque occasion
nous sommes attachés à la culture et à
la création et nous sommes attachés à
des valeurs que nous portons qui ont nom
diversité culturelle
oui identité culturelle nous considérons
en effet que c'est une composante
essentielle d'une république moderne et
c'est finalement la part d'humanité qui
nous revient dans un monde en
transformation constante est aujourd'hui
en crise c'est aussi un signe que nous
avons voulu adresser aux jeunes français
et aux jeunes talents qui ont besoin de
notre reconnaissance pour leur travail
notamment pour leur travail de création
qui ont besoin aussi de notre soutien
dans notre confiance dans leurs oeuvres
de créateurs
imaginons un seul instant qu'on dise
qu'on dise aux jeunes générations qui
veulent s'engager dans le monde de la
création
eh bien écoutez quoi que vous fassiez
vous serez demain spoliés de vos droits
vous ne serez pas récompenser de votre
travail
on peut imaginer que ce serait
décourageant et qu'il n'y aurait pas
beaucoup de vocations qui s'engageraient
dans le monde de la création
vivre en société et c'est aussi un signe
adressé aux jeunes générations
cela veut dire qu'il ya des valeurs
excès valeur doit être respectée cela
veut dire qu'il ya du sens à vivre en
société
et cela aussi veut dire qu'il ya une
hiérarchie à respecter de ses valeurs et
de ce sens donner à notre vie en société
cette hiérarchie ce n'est pas forcément
spontanément ce qui existe plus sur
internet
internet est un monde plat dans lequel
tous les usagers toutes les valeurs ont
à peu près le même sens et l'avait
mirarchi c'est un monde dans lequel tout
à peu près le même dimension et tous les
partis y sont équivalent en termes de
durée de fréquentation
donc à nous de remettre du sens et à
nous de donner une hiérarchie à cette
consommation frénétique mais
intéressante et cette gourmandise cette
manière de dieu qui sont sur la toile
certes internet
et donc un territoire virtuel c'est une
terre sympathique et accueillante
cependant elle doit être polis et au
sens républicain du terme c'est à dire
que nous devons faire en sorte
qu'internet soit respectueuse des doigts
et donc des droits de chacun le sénat
par rapport à ça a pris ses
responsabilités il a répondu en
particulier ou scepticisme ambiant on a
souvent entendu cette question va-t-on
laisser durablement piller les oeuvres
sur internet
nous avons également souhaité répondre à
une autre interrogation qui peut être
même un désespoir de certains créateurs
qui se disait va-t-on laisser
s'effondrer l'économie de la création je
dois vous rappeler qu'il y à 2 4% de la
population active de notre pays qui
travaillent dans l'univers la création
et en temps de crise comme nous la
connaissons aujourd'hui ce sont des
choses qui portent et qui interpelle
hans adam ii nos concitoyens qui sont
très inquiets quant à leur devenir
et puis c'est aussi une réponse
peut-être que nous avons voulu apporter
à une forme de cynisme ambiant une sorte
de double langage puisque on entend
parfois dire va-t-on fliquer les
internautes va-t-on pénaliser les
internautes
nous croyons au contraire qu'il s'agit
pas ni de fliquer ni de pénaliser il
s'agit tout simplement de faire
respecter un ensemble de liberté mais
aussi de droits des uns et des autres si
l'on veut que la diversité que la
protection des oeuvres est encore un
sens et si l'on veut se détourner de
quelques abus ou me voir même d'un
certain populisme qui viserait à dire
que tout se ressemble tous peut être
consommée
quelles qu'en soient les conséquences
alors quelles réponses concrètes avant
nous apporter à l'issue de cette cmp
je ne reviendrai pas très longuement sur
tous les débats que nous avons eus sim
est peut-être utile de résumer
quelques-unes des conclusions de cette
cmp d'abord où le savez nous avons
toujours voulu promouvoir l'offre légale
parce qu'il faut qu'il y ait une offre
légale forte et diverses
si l'on veut que l'internaute se sentent
à la fois j'irai en sécurité sur
internet mais aussi pouvoir consommer le
maximum des oeuvres de création
donc nous avons souhaité qu'il y ait une
concertation entre les producteurs et
les acteurs et la suite de nos collègues
d'assemblée nationale
nous avons adopté ce que l'on appelait
le recueil des usages qui est finalement
un cadre incitatif qui permet de
rassembler les professionnels de ce
secteur 2
manière à ce qu'ils puissent établir un
ensemble des usages qui permettront dans
l'avenir de mieux faire circuler les
oeuvres sur internet
nous avons souhaité également que la
haute autorité l'hadopi puisse pouvoir
référencer des portails de manière à
apporter davantage d'informations et
valoriser davantage l'offre légale nous
avons également souhaité après de
nombreux débats dont on se souvient ici
qu'il y est un cadre fixé pour la
chronologie des médias est que cette
chronologie des médias permettent une
offre légale de meilleure qualité sans
pour autant mettre en difficulté voire
mettre en péril le financement des
oeuvres cinématographiques
c'est la raison pour laquelle cmp a dull
adopter des délais de sortie pour les
dvd avec une date pivot qui est de 4
mois et autour de quatre mois avec des
possibilité de raccourcir ou de
prolonger les délais en fonction d'un
certain nombre de contraintes ou
d'accords qui interviendront nous avons
également souhaité au delà de l'offre
légale que la haute autorité sans
revenir sous ce qui avait été déjà à
accorder à savoir que c'est une bien sûr
une autorité qu'il être irréprochable
qu'elle doit favoriser l'éveil l'offre
légale mais nous avons souhaité
renforcer encore le caractère
pédagogique de son accompagnement de
l'internaute vers un chemin plus
vertueux et nous avons souhaité que ce
chemin soit balisé notamment en
sécurisant la haute autorité et en la
rendant encore plus indépendante et
notre cola et catherine morin desailly a
rappelé un amendement au terme duquel le
plat présidence de la hadopi doit être
là aussi indépendante et donc le
président sera élu par ses pairs
nous avons également souhaité supprimer
en cmp la sanction alternative que nous
avions adopté ici qui visait et
éventuellement à moduler le débit parce
que c'était quelque chose qui était
compliquée à mettre en oeuvre et donc
nous avons accepté nous sénat sans
discussion la suppression de cette
mesure en revanche nous étions ferme sur
la la suspension du paiement qui avaient
été souhaitées par nos collègues de
l'assemblée
or il nous paraît utile de dire que si
au bout du processus qui est encore une
fois un processus pédagogique syli à
sanction cette sanction c'est la
suspension
de l'abonnement internet mais c'est en
même temps le maintien du paiement de
cet abonnement tout simplement parce que
c'est un problème de droit c'est un
problème de contrat signé entre le
fournisseur d'accès et l'abonné et qui
ne nous apparaît pas utile en tout cas
pas du tout souhaitable qu'on revienne
sur un contrat signé d'ailleurs par
analogie à saint thonan nous faisait
remarquer que quand vous avez une
voiture que vous payer les traites pour
acheter votre voiture lors le jour où
vous fait supprimer votre permis de
conduire vous continuer à payer votre
est votre voiture continue à vous
appartenir et glaner un peu d'eux-mêmes
dans l'offre triple play que contracté à
sa dom22 concitoyens et là je voudrais
m'élever même si on sait que ça ne sert
pas toujours à grand-chose de s'élever
et ça devrait s'élever contre certains
raccourcis
ce matin en me levant j'ai ouvert la
télévision sur une grande chaîne du
service public et j'étais abasourdi
d'entendre que les sénateurs avaient
annoncé la double peine ce gip à double
peine s'agit tout simplement fait
respecter la loi de faire respecter le
droit et se respectent et 1 contre
et puisque je me suis élevé contre
certains raccourcis qui n'ont rien à
voir la réalité je voudrais quand même
saluer le travail de la chaîne public
sénat qui a été de ce point de vue là
très pédagogique et qui explique bien
comment les choses se passeront si les
internautes veulent bien accepter le
respect du droit
nous avons également souhaité en cmp
qu'il n'y ait pas d' amnistie pour les
contrevenants à la loi dans le cadre de
la loi davdsi pourquoi tout simplement
parce que ce sont des contrevenants qui
avait juré une pratique du piratage qui
n'avait rien à voir avec ce que font les
internautes classiques si je peux dire
ce qui piratait pour consommer
personnellement quelques films où
quelques musiques et qu'on avait affaire
ici à des gros trafiquants et ça
n'aurait pas été un signe très très
élégant les avis des internautes que de
leur dire que finalement ce qui avait
piraté pour en faire commerce
ce voyez amnistiés nous avons également
souhaité abandonner une mesure que nos
collègues l'assemblée avait mis en place
qui était la possibilité d'avoir une
forme de circonstances atténuantes
lorsque l'internaute ne trouvait pas en
ligne une offre légale et qu'il allait
la pirater n'ont pas souhaité retenir
cette mesure tout simplement parce
qu'elle était contraire
autre idée du développement d'une offre
légale et si on explique que finalement
ce que l'on trouve pas sur l'offre
légale on peut le trouver
je dirais en volant et bien ce moment là
ce n'est pas un bon signe adressé aux
aux offres légales et donc à tous ceux
qui font un effort d'avoir des
catalogues en ligne
suffisant c'est un petit peu comme si on
vous disait puisque vous n'avez pas
trouvé dans le supermarché au coin de la
rue le produit que vous souhaitiez est
bien allé le volet chez votre voisin et
ainsi vous serez satisfait donc c'est un
signe qui ne paraissait pas très positif
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
n'avons pas souhaité l'adopter au final
on peut dire que la haute autorité à
travers nos différentes discussions et
aux thèmes la cmp est à la fois une
haute autorité indépendante dont toute
indépendance a été rappelé et sécurisée
qui est une autorité qui a également je
rêve tout un tas de précaution
concernant les données personnelles et
la vie personnelle de nos concitoyens
c'est une haute autorité dont la
première mission sera de renforcer
l'offre légale à la fois par les
labellisations part j'irai et north une
sorte de soutien à l'offre légale mais
c'est aussi une haute autorité qui verra
son rôle renforcé dans le domaine de
l'information apportée aux internautes
dans le domaine de l'explication et dans
le domaine du conseil et puis au final
bien sûr il peut y avoir une sanction
parce qu'il n'y a pas de chemin
pédagogique sans sanctions éventuelles
je voudrais également d'un mot redire
que nous avons en cmp étudier tout ce
qui concerne la presse puisque les états
généraux de la presse se sont terminées
et que même si nous n'avons pas eu
l'occasion d'en discuter ici d'en
débattre en séance au sénat
nous avons en cmp bien sûr adopté à se
nomme de mesures qui permettent à la
fois de sécuriser le droit d'auteur des
journalistes de conforter le statut
d'éditeur de presse en ligne et cela se
traduit donc de manière relative par un
ensemble de mesures qui sont comprises
dans ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le
média global puisque la presse va de
plus en plus sur les nouveaux médias la
presse papier et la presse internet sont
maintenant très complémentaires l'un de
l'autre et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons souhaité adopter en cmp un
texte équilibré qui vise à
apporter davantage de sécurité juridique
aux éditeurs mais qui garantit de la
même manière des droits de propriété
intellectuelle aux oeuvres des
journalistes donc les éditeurs pourront
exploiter les oeuvres mais ils devront
assurer une juste rémunération de
l'auteur dans le cadre de d'accord qui
pourront pas de contractuels à partir du
moment où la loi sera votée
donc au bout de cette démarche longue
qui a duré près de 18 mois je pense que
le texte auquel nous sommes arrivés est
un texte qui est d'abord un signal fort
en direction du monde de la création et
nous redisons ce matin au moment de
voter aux auteurs et aux artistes que
notre pays leur fait confiance que nous
avons besoin d'eux et que nous avons
besoin d'eux pour continuer à agir est à
créer aux comptes pour la création et
pour la culture mais nous avons aussi
besoin d'eux parce que la culture est un
des moteurs à la fois de notre mode de
vie et un mode de vie qui a besoin d'une
économie plus vivace encore nous
protégeons leurs droits à travers ce
texte est finalement puisque nous sommes
dans une enceinte qui est une des
chambres de la république
nous avons souhaité bien sûr renforcer
la liberté la liberté de créer la
liberté d'offrir le maximum d'eux vont
sur internet et la liberté du découvrir
toutes ces oeuvres mais nous avons
souhaité que cela se fasse dans le cadre
de l'égalité républicaine
ce soit une égalité de traitement des
uns et des autres nous avions expliqué
ici que le droit d eux ne doit pas être
supérieure aux droits des autres
il doit y avoir une égalité des droits
entre les internautes et les créateurs
de manière et vous voyez venir à ce que
la fraternité l'emportent
c'est à dire que nous soyons dans une
république qui soit à la fois qu'ils
s'adaptent aux nouvelles technologies
mais qui n'abdique qui n'abdique pas de
ses principes et de ses valeurs la
république ne doit pas abdiquer ses
valeurs et ses principes
elles doivent s'adapter aux nouvelles
technologies mais ne pas se laisser
engloutir par les nouvelles technologies
c'était le sens de notre travail et je
voudrais très sincèrement remercier tous
les collègues qui m'ont accompagné en
tant que rapporteur
que ce soit au sein de la commission où
dans cette assemblée première c'est le
président de notre commission jacques
gendre
adressez un sincère et très très très
légitime remerciements à toute notre
équipe de la commission je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur d'un ami je
crois que vous avez souhaité intervenir
la fin de la discussion générale je vais
donc dans discussions nationales de la
parole à catherine morin dessailly pour
le groupe de l'union centriste et pour
dix minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues chaque jour plus de
8 millions de mp3 et plus d'un demi
million de films sont échangés
illégalement sur internet
ces chiffres très alarmant montre à quel
point les industries culturelles
musicales et cinématographiques sont
menacés il rappelle aussi l'urgence de
trouver une réponse adaptée afin
d'endiguer ce phénomène d' atteintes
massives aux droits de propriété
intellectuelle et à la création
le contournement sur internet des règles
de la propriété intellectuelle demeure
je le rappelle à ce jour assimilé au
délit de contrefaçon passible dans notre
arsenal juridique de trois ans de prison
et trois cent mille euros damende
pragmatique le groupe centriste approuve
donc la mise en oeuvre de mesures
alternatives à cette pénalisation
systématique et inapplicable des
internautes
instituée par la loi davdsi contre
laquelle d'ailleurs ils avaient voté
notre groupe a toujours montré son
attachement la prévention est un système
mesure et de gradation des sanctions
pourraient précise je dois dire que
certains membres de notre groupe
émettent des réserves sur ce qui est
qualifié de double peine à savoir la
suspension de l'accès à internet
attaché à la poursuite du paiement de
l'abonnement pour autant il mesure les
difficultés que cela suscite pour les
offres triple play
il est vrai que le principe de la
suspension partielle télévision et
téléphone qui doivent rester disponibles
implique de déterminer le coût
individualisé de l'accès à internet ce
qui est difficilement mesurable du fait
de la mutualisation des coûts
d'exploitation la boucle locale et du
service adsl
autrement dit dans la mesure le projet
loi implique de dissocier des services
qui sont toujours qu'ils ont toujours
été proposé dans le cadre d'offres faut
faire taire global et que cette
dissociation un coût important
l'afa question est de savoir qui doit
supporter ce coût convenons-en il
apparaît donc difficile de faire
supporter à elle faillit les
conséquences engendrées par les
téléchargements illégaux d'un de ses
abonnés de la même manière doit-il
revenir aux contribuables de s'acquitter
des conséquences de cette faute
en supposant que l'état aura été mis à
contribution
au-delà de ces questionnements je tenais
à revenir sur les avancées du projet
auquel le groupe
centriste est particulièrement sensible
en premier lieu le texte issu de la cmp
ne remet pas en cause les grands
équilibres atteints à l'issue des
accords interprofessionnels dit de
l'elysée qui ont été à la base du
travail et de l'élaboration du projet de
loi
de même il ne remet pas en cause les
grands équilibres du texte tel que voté
en première lecture au sénat et sur
lequel s'était dégagé une quasi
unanimité de notre assemblée
en second lieu s'agissant du procédé de
désignation du président de l'hadopi
un amendement avait été adopté par un de
nos collègues députés
pardon par nos collègues députés à
savoir la nomination du président de
l'hadopi par décret or le texte adopté
au sénat comme l'a rappelé notre
collègue michel thiollière prévoyait que
le président de l'hadopi soit élu au
sein des membres du collège de la haute
assemblée j'étais particulièrement
sensible à cette modification car notre
goût qu'on avait été porteur lors de son
examen par la haute assemblée de cet
amendement qui prévoyait d'abandonner la
nomination par décret au profit d'une
élection par ce système d'élection sur
le modèle de celui retenu par la cnil
c'est l'indépendance et l'impartialité
de cette haute autorité qui n'est pas
une autorité comme les autres qui se
trouve garantie le texte issu de la cmp
confirme également les dispositions
faveur d'une mise à disposition plus
immédiate de l'offre légale
que ce soit dans le domaine de la
musique avec un amendement que j'avais
déposé qui a permis la suppression des
drm levant ainsi un des principaux
freins au déploiement des offres
nouvelles
ou encore des oeuvres cinématographiques
pour lequel la cmp a finalement tranché
en faveur du dispositif voté à
l'assemblée nationale qui prévoit des
les ramener à quatre mois entre la
sortie en salles et l'exploitation sous
forme de vidéos g
pour autant nous sommes conscients que
cette loi ne règle pas définitivement la
question du téléchargement illégal et
plus largement celle du piratage
numérique les technologies évolueront
toujours plus vite que le droit et il
faudra être vigilant pour ce que nous
nous adaptions et que le législateur à
la lumière des travaux de l'hadopi qui
est chargé de veiller aussi bien
les mauvaises pratiques a suscité les
bonnes continue de réfléchir à des
améliorations futures
je le répète cette loi qui sera
certainement que transitoire doit être
une étape importante dans une prise de
conscience collectif une prise de
conscience de la part des internautes
tout d'abord il est indispensable de
faire passer un double message clair la
culture a un coût et les droits de
propriété intellectuelle doivent être
respectées à quoi bon multiplier les
canaux de diffusion si à terme la
diversité des contenus disparaît s'il
est convenu étrangers deviennent
prédominantes la création française a
été asséché je me félicite d'ailleurs
que le soient parvenus à un texte qui
favorise la compagne de nouveaux usages
à la fois protecteur des oeuvres et
ouvert au monde de la création
venant se substituer aux pratiques qui
au contraire lui nuisent les
consommateurs peuvent aujourd'hui
naviguer d'une plateforme de
téléchargement une autre d'un baladeur à
un autre en gardant la pleine jouissance
d'oeuvre légalement acquises le marché
du disque vendu à l'unité on le sait a
fait long feu et s'ouvre aujourd'hui une
profusion de nouveaux modèles
plateformes légales mais aussi streaming
catalogue des offres en tout cas
technologies conviviales et aux prix
attractifs
une prise de conscience des internautes
mais également une prise de conscience
de la part des créateurs qu'ils soient
producteurs éditeurs réalisateurs
artistes
en effet ils doivent aussi se remettre
en cause et penser à s'adapter a trouvé
de modèle et nouveau modèle économique
adapté à l'heure du net
il faut aussi qu'il se rend compte des
évolutions et que ce le phénomène
internet n'est pas temporaire mais qu'il
est aujourd'hui une réalité durable
qu'il faut transformer en atout plus
qu'à chercher à le combattre
à cet effet l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés les propriétaires et
fournisseurs de contenu doit se
rapprocher encore davantage demain et
l'expérience monde aujourd'hui que le
monde de la création et le monde
numérique ne peuvent plus continuer à
s'ignorer doivent réfléchir ensemble au
développement de moyens innovants qui
permettront demain d'offrir aux
internautes de multiples possibilités
d'accès au savoir et aux oeuvres de la
création enfin concernant les sanctions
je suis heureuse que le texte final
favorise la transaction plus pédagogique
ce qui laisse l'objectif premier de
cette réforme le passage de la
suspension de l'accès internet à deux
mois rétabli à différentiel rendant la
transaction plus attractive certains ont
vu dans ce retour à un minimum de deux
mois un renforcement de la répression
en réalité je pense que l'objectif est
tout autre il s'agit de renforcer
l'attractivité de la transaction fasse à
la sanction sèche
or je reste persuadé qu'une transaction
entre l'hadopi et l'abonné pour
l'établissement de la sanction sera
toujours gage de plus de souplesse mais
surtout renforcera le caractère
pédagogique de l'ascension enfin je
terminerai en évoquant la prévention je
l' ai déjà dit l'objectif avec la
réponse graduée est de faire évoluer les
mentalités et les comportements
l'éducation et la pédagogie nous sommes
est essentielle pour que les jeunes
générations prennent conscience des
conséquences du téléchargement illicite
sur la création artistique en 2006 lors
les travaux sur la loi davdsi nous
avions plaidé l'importance de
l'éducation de nos concitoyens à la
culture dans ses pratiques de
téléchargement peuvent accréditer l'idée
que tout est gratuit et que la culture
ne coûte rien or c'est méconnaître
investissement personnel intellectuel et
financier ainsi que le travail des
artistes d'ailleurs sachant cela comment
peut-on laisser dire qu encadrer
l'utilisation des oeuvres est une
atteinte aux droits essentiels de
l'homme
revêtant un caractère liberticide
je trouve pour ma part cela assez
consternant je me félicite que le texte
prévoit toujours une information des
élèves dans le cas de l'éducation
nationale il est également bienvenu que
les fournisseurs d'accès à internet
soient mis à contribution dans les
actions sensibilisation des internautes
par des messages appropriés
en tout cas il ne faut pas perdre de vue
que l'enjeu de ce projet de loi est bien
d'assurer l'avenir de la création
culturelle comme l'a dit le rapporteur
michel thiollière et qu'il faut garantir
un juste équilibre entre les droits
légitimes des auteurs sans lesquelles il
ne saurait y avoir de créations
artistiques et culturelles et bien sûr
les droits des citoyens à l'accès au
partage et à la diffusion de la culture
des savoirs et de l'information que
permet ce formidable espace de liberté
et qu'est internet en tout cas il
convient de rester âme dans le
traitement de ce sujet difficile
aussi je tiens à saluer particulièrement
le travail de chacun bien sûr celui de
mon collègue michel thiollière mais
aussi celui de bruno retailleau qui a le
mérite de projets avec courage de bonnes
questions
même si certains n'ont pas encore obtenu
de réponse
et puis bien sûr les administrateurs de
la commission des affaires culturelles
et des affaires économiques
je vous remercie de votre attention vous
aurez compris mes chers collègues que le
vote du groupe centriste sera en faveur
de la loi
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
ici changé à la parole à serge lagauche
le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous voici donc
parvenu au terme de l'examen du si
controversé projet de loi favorisant la
diffusion et la protection de la
protection de la création sur internet
le marasme économique dans lequel sont
plongés d industrie phonographique et la
fragilité des industries
cinématographiques dans le contexte de
l'avènement du numérique ou commander
d'agir en particulier contre la
piraterie
nous déplorons que ce projet de loi a
été présenté au sénat
près d'une année après la signature des
accords olivennes dans cet intervalle
rien n'a été fait pour consolider le
consensus obtenu par la signature des
accords de l'elysée
si bien que certains signataires ils ont
depuis dénoncé les frictions entre les
différents acteurs de la filière auteurs
producteurs diffuseurs fournisseurs
d'accès et internautes consommateurs se
sont ralliés près de 18 mois vous ont
été nécessaires pour faire voter en
urgence le texte par le parlement
au final après l'échec de la loi davdsi
vous avez mis plus de deux ans et demi
pour tenter de trouver une réponse
adaptée au piratage destructeur pour la
création les auteurs je ne reviendrai
pas sur le dispositif de la riposte
graduée
il a été très largement décrypter
d'abord par le sénat puis par
l'assemblée nationale et est issu de la
commission mixte paritaire
il nous semble un compromis acceptable
entre les droits et obligations des
internautes des créateurs et des haies
failli
toutefois s'agissant de l'assistance ion
de l'abonnement internet derniers états
de riposte nous sommes satisfaits de la
solution retenue par la commission mixte
paritaire qui est d'ailleurs celle que
nous avions voté en première lecture au
sénat
les abonnés sanctionnés devront
continuer de payer leur abonnement du
temps de la sanction
on ne peut pas rendre responsables les
fournisseurs d'accès internet les
manquements commis par leurs abonnés
d'autant que le triple play leur
permettra de continuer de recevoir la
télévision et téléphone les nouvelles
pratiques d'accès aux biens culturels
par le biais du net et le développement
de l'attractivité de l'offre légale de
films rendent est par ailleurs
nécessaire une adaptation la chronologie
des médias le groupe socialiste du sénat
avait d'ailleurs déposé un amendement en
première lecture
pour ramener la fenêtre d'exploitation
des films en dvd entre 4 et 9 mois après
la sortie en salles
nous étions finalement rallié à
l'amendement voté à l'initiative d'un
soutien hier et de la commission des
affaires culturelles qui souhaitaient en
quelque sorte donné une dernière chance
à la négociation interprofessionnelle
pour parvenir à un accord sur ce délai
cet accord n'est malheureusement pas
intervenue et c'est de manière fort
opportune que la commission mixte
paritaire unanime à ramener le délai de
sortie des films en dvd à quatre mois
après la sortie de la grande salle avec
des possibilités de dérogations selon le
succès ou la nature du film qui peut
nécessiter un temps d'exposition sape
les importants pour rencontrer son
public
s'agissant de la vidéo à la demande et
bénéficiera des mêmes délais que le dvd
si aucun accord interprofessionnel
intervenu dans le mois qui suivra la
publication de la présente loi au
journal officiel et nous en sommes
satisfaits
cette évolution la chronologie des
médias devraient renforcer
l'attractivité de l'offre légale de
films et contribuer parallèlement à
l'érosion du piratage
s'agissant de la musique des
dispositions sont prévues pour inciter
les éditeurs phonographiques à renoncer
autres mesures techniques de protection
qui empêcherait l'interopérabilité des
offres sur tous les supports lecture
c'est également positif pour accentuer
l'intérêt pour leurs frais galles
numérique de musique
le texte issu de la commission mixte
paritaire n'est cependant pas parfait
loin s'en faut
si davantage de poser dans le marbre de
la loi le principe selon lequel le
piratage des oeuvres culturelles est un
vol vis-à-vis du droit d'auteur auquel
il convient de répondre par une sanction
graduée et proportionnée votre projet de
loi manque cruellement d'un voile et
pédagogique qu'il aurait fallu
développer en amont de son vote par le
parlement
il faut expliquer aux jeunes internautes
et leurs parents les titulaires de
l'abonnement internet les dangers pour
la création artistique du piratage des
oeuvres insisté sur le fait qu' internet
comme partout ailleurs la gratuité
n'existe pas de tout se paie et que
cette rémunération directe ou indirecte
et la source indispensable du
financement du cinéma de la musique et
de l'ensemble de la création artistique
il faut sensibiliser d'un internaute sur
le caractère vital pour la création
artistique de la défense du droit à
rémunération des auteurs
pour éviter que le dispositif de la
riposte graduée ne soit pas compris pas
à succès et se soldent au final par un
échec pour la rémunération de l'ensemble
de la chaîne des ayants droits de la
création via internet
le texte issu de l'assemblée nationale
prévoyait que tout comme pour les
président de radio france et france
télévisions le président de l'hadopi
soit nommé par décret autant dire dans
le contexte actuel par l'elysée la
commission mixte paritaire à venir sur
cette disposition en prévoyant que le
président de l'hadopi sera élu par les
membres du grillage dispositions très
singe pour notre démocratie
nous regrettons tous que ce texte ne
répond pas de manière satisfaisante à la
question fondamentale de la rémunération
et la création à l'ère numérique
un modèle reste à inventer et la
révolution numérique appelle une
vigilance particulière pour assurer la
préservation des développements du
cinéma de l'édition et de la musique
enregistrée dans le contexte actuel
d'érosion des recettes publicitaires sur
tous les supports d'information de
communication il ne nous sommes pas
suffisant d'encouragement des économies
qui consiste à asseoir une partie de la
rémunération des auteurs sur le partage
des recettes publicitaires de plus en
plus incertaine
simultanément il nous faudra revisiter
le thème de la démocratisation
culturelle
en prenant en compte les nouvelles
pratiques artistiques et sociales qui se
déploie sur le net
pour notre part nous serons toujours
disponibles pour participer à la
recherche d'une solution économique
permettant le respect du droit d'auteur
tout en favorisant la diffusion
culturelle pour le plus grand nombre
en rassemblant des internautes et les
artistes et non les opposants pour les
raisons que j'ai évoquées
nous restons sceptiques sur l'efficacité
de ce texte et sa proportion réduire
significativement le piratage des
oeuvres afin de manifester notre soutien
indéfectible aux auteurs dont les
oeuvres sont piratés nous avions accepté
de soutenir votre projet de loi lors de
son examen par le sénat
cependant madame la ministre vous n'avez
que trop tardé pour faire adopter ce
texte
permettez moi d'ajouter que le moment
monsieur christian kjaer prévoyante la
collaboration des journalistes dans une
entreprise de presse est désormais multi
supports est tout à fait inacceptable
sur le fond
sans l'accord des journalistes et que
sur la forme il représente pour nous un
cavalier un débat sur la presse au sein
de notre assemblée nous paraît
indispensable pour toutes ces raisons le
groupe du sénat du socialiste du sénat
s'abstiendra sur ce texte
mais très sincèrement ne pouvons que
souhaiter la diminution du piratage et
la prise de conscience par la majorité
des internautes des méfaits du piratage
pour la création artistique et la
diversité culturelle
merci mon cher collègue dans la suite de
discussions générales
la parole est un madame françoise
laborde pour le groupe rdse
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la révolution
technologique que nous traversons depuis
dix ans a eu pour effet une croissance
exponentielle des échanges de données
des logiciels de pardon s'cusez moi
ainsi que le développement des logiciels
de téléchargement d'oeuvres musicales ou
cinématographiques sur internet
le monde de la culture dans son ensemble
doit faire face à cette révolution
technologique et aux bouleversements
profonds qu'elle entraîne avec le
passage au numérique et la modification
des modes de consommation des biens
culturels
les industriels qui ont de leur côté mis
en place les premiers verrous anticopie
pour tenter de protéger les droits
d'auteur et par conséquent la production
artistique elle même cela n'a évidemment
pas suffi à enrayer le phénomène du
téléchargement illégal qui n'a cessé de
s'accélérer
suivant ainsi l'évolution des supports
et des conditions des changes des
oeuvres culturelles avec l'apparition de
nouvelles plates formes et de nouveaux
logiciels de téléchargement
comment dans ces conditions la
législation peut-elle ne pas avoir en
permanence un temps de retard
aujourd'hui les enjeux économiques de la
copie par les particuliers sont
considérables comme en témoignent les
chiffres des téléchargements quotidiens
de films qui en france sont équivalents
au nombre d'entrées en salles sans
oublier la chute des ventes de disques
de 50% en cinq ans c'est donc bien un
secteur économique et culturel entier
qui est en péril le texte dont nous
examinons aujourd'hui la dernière
mouture a fait l'objet de beaucoup de
polémiques de débats et a déchaîné
certaine passion au delà parfois il faut
bien l'admettre du raisonnable et
notamment sur les bancs de nos collègues
députés
il est cependant fondamental de revenir
à l'essentiel est de ne pas se laisser
submerger par l'émotion et la démagogie
utilisait parfois et par certains ces
dernières semaines aujourd'hui l'enjeu
majeur est bel et bien de protéger la
création culturelle pour réussir l'état
pédagogique est incontournable
responsabiliser notamment les plus
jeunes qui sont les principaux
utilisateurs des nouveaux moyens de
communication
notre camp capacité à sensibiliser les
consommateurs à la notion de droits
d'auteur
conditionnera la réussite du sauvetage
de la production artistique l'ère du
numérique et du une opportunité sans
précédent pour la culture
l'accès à de plus en plus d'informations
pour le plus grand nombre représente un
potentiel extraordinaire que nous devons
apprendre à apprivoiser et à utiliser à
bon escient
mais bien évidemment cela ne devra
jamais se faire au détriment des
artistes leur protection est au coeur de
nos préoccupations à tous cela va de soi
le compromis auquel la commission mixte
paritaire est arrivé et auquel j'ai eu
l'honneur de contribuer me semble tout à
fait équilibrée même si pas toujours
satisfaisant mais c'est bien là le
propre des compromis et des équilibres
car le texte sur lequel nous allons
devoir nous prononcer tout à l'heure
sera parfois difficile à appliquer
mais il a vite surtout au respect de la
création artistique
le principe de riposte graduée qui
s'appliquera dans la sphère familiale
éducative m'apparaît comme un bon outil
efficace et pédagogique à l'égard des
utilisateurs d'internet plus ou moins
mal intentionnés les pirates sanctionnés
par la loi davdsi seront donc
sanctionnés en vertu du délit de
contrefaçon des droits voisins
par ailleurs la limitation du débit des
internautes pirates ne semblait pas une
solution adaptée
la suspension de leur connexion est une
sanction compréhensible et proportionnée
dans le cadre des offres triple play ne
sera suspendu que la connexion internet
est pas l'accès aux autres services
c'est une bonne disposition il a aussi
été décidé en cmp
à juste titre de mon point de vue de ne
pas accompagner la suspension de la
connexion internet d'une dispense du
paiement de l'abonnement
il ne s'agit là nullement d'une double
peine mais tout simplement d'une mesure
d'équité et de justice
pour quelle raison un abonné pirates ne
respectant pas ses obligations
serait-il dispensé de son obligation
contractuelle de payer son abonnement
et pourquoi le fournisseur d'accès
devrait-il dans un tel cas prendre à sa
charge le poids financier de la sanction
prononcée contre sont abonnés il
pourrait dès lors se retourner contre
l'état et faire assumer
financièrement la sanction par les
autres contribuables cette éventualité
justifie pleinement notre décision afin
d'appliquer de contrôler les nouveaux
dispositifs la mise en place d'une
autorité publique et indépendante de
régulation
la haute autorité pour la diffusion des
oeuvres et la protection des droits sur
internet hadopi était incontournable et
je souligne que la cmp a retenu la
proposition du sénat de faire élire et
non pas nommé son président c'est par
les temps qui courent un progrès qui je
crois doit être souligné et qui est une
fois encore à l'honneur de la haute
assemblée au delà de la mission
pédagogique le volet sanction sera
assurée par cette nouvelle autorité
sa mission est de lutter contre le
piratage de surveiller et d'encourager
le développement de l'offre légale en
ligne
la cnp est d'ailleurs précisé que
l'hadopi n'aura pas à tenir compte du
contenu de l'offre légale pour apprécier
la gravité de ceux des manquements la
sanction doit être appliquée quelle que
soit l'offre proposée
d'autant plus que son développement est
pour l'instant insuffisant j'insiste
vraiment sur ce dernier point il est
fondamental de développer une est une
offre légale alternative avant de
conclure j'aborderai madame la ministre
quelques-unes des dispositions
introduites à l'assemblée nationale est
validée par la cmp réformant le droit
d'auteur des journalistes
elles répondent à certaines
recommandations issues des états
généraux de la presse de l'automne
dernier la législation relative aux
droits d'auteur des journalistes étaient
désuètes et inadaptée à la nouvelle
économie du secteur de la presse tant
pour les journalistes pour les
entreprises de presse le droit était
devenu préjudiciable au regard des
changements rendue indispensable par le
développement des nouveaux suuuper de
transmission de l'information
désormais l'ensemble des supports d'un
titre de presse sera susceptible de
publier le travail d'un journaliste
ayant conclu un contrat de travail avec
l'entreprise
mais si tel ne devait pas être le cas
cela serait précisée dans le contrat de
travail ou pour les pigistes dans tout
autre convention de collaboration
ponctuelle
dans ces conditions madame la ministre
nous prenons acte aujourd'hui de
l'aboutissement d'un travail de longue
haleine
qui a permis de mettre en avant la
complexité et les divergences des points
de vue mais il faut souhaiter que ces
débats conduiront à une réelle prise de
conscience car la création et les
artistes doivent être respectées pour
accompagner cette clarification nous
attendons madame la ministre la mise en
place d'une politique culturelle bien
sûr plus ambitieuses notamment en termes
de moyens budgétaires et
particulièrement en faveur des
producteurs indépendants et des auteurs
la majorité des membres du groupe rds se
prononcera en faveur de l'adoption du
texte issu des travaux de la commission
mixte paritaire
merci à tous les membres de la
commission culturelle en particulier son
président mais aussi son rapporteur et
ses administrateurs
merci monsieur maingain la suite de
discussions géré à la parole et à notre
collègue yves renard groupe crc
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues fort de l'exception
culturelle de son système de soutien
juridique fiscal social industriel
notre pays est riche d'une production
musicale et cinématographique une
qualité et d'une diversité reconnu et
souvent envie à l'étranger il est
évidemment essentiel de préserver cette
vitalité culturelle et artistique unique
au monde symbole de résistance à
l'uniformisation et à la standardisation
la culture est la clé de voûte du
développement humain
sa défense est un impératif éthique et
humaniste et je suis persuadé que la
révolution numérique loin d'être
l'ennemi des artistes offre
potentiellement de nouvelles
opportunités de développement de la
création de démocratisation culturelle
la dématérialisation favorise l'accès
aux oeuvres de l'esprit et rend possible
cette utopie de leur partage
désintéressé et sans limite
ceci dit le financement de la création
et la rémunération équitable des
artistes interprètes n'en restent pas
moins des enjeux déterminants
les mutations en cours ne sont elles pas
une belle occasion de remettre les
artistes au coeur des dispositifs de
soutien
d'autant que la plupart d'entre eux
vivent dans une très grande précarité
est il légitime par exemple que l'auteur
ne perçoivent qu'une part très infime de
2 à 7 centimes par téléchargement sur
les sites légaux alors que la crise
actuelle du capitalisme rhénan cause le
profit pour le profit comme la
financiarisation du monde alors que les
jeunes générations en deux ans ou de
moins en moins le réflexe de
l'appropriation mais davantage celui de
l' usage que la plupart de nos
concitoyens reconnaisse toute
l'importance de donner aux artistes et
moyens de vivre leur travail le moment
n'est-il pas venu d'inventer un nouveau
modèle économique du droit d'auteur
adapté à l'univers numérique et propices
à la création
malheureusement ce défi est évacuée du
projet de loi pourtant intitulé création
et internet
hormis la révision de la chronologie des
médias pour la sortie des films en dvd
il ne s'attache aucunement impulser de
nouvelles mesures visant à améliorer les
offres légales sur le web
malgré un débat riche au sénat à
l'assemblée nationale comme dans la
société civile et de nombreuses
propositions innovantes au service des
auteurs et de la création
le texte arrêté sans c'est vrai ce
essentiellement marquée par une vision
par trop répressive à l'efficacité
aléatoire et surtout il ne répond pas à
cette question cruciale comment
améliorer la rétribution des créateurs
tout en s'appuyant sur la circulation
sans précédent des oeuvres de l'esprit
nécessaires au développement de la
société de la connaissance comme la loi
davdsi la loi adoptée sera-t-il un coup
d'épée dans l'eau
les fameux verrou numérique instauré par
l'adav s'ils sont peu à peu en
coordonnées et les sanctions pénales de
sept premières lois répressives sont
tellement 10 conventionnés qu'elles
n'ont pu être appliquée l'hadopi risque
de connaître le même sort car elle ne
sera pas en capacité d'inverser
l'irrépressible courant des réseaux
numériques qui ont durablement
bouleverser les usages les économies et
les rapports aux ordres et production
culturelle et artistique fondée sur les
mauvaises analyses des majors qui
souhaitent arrêter le progrès au nom du
profit
ce projet de loi se présente comme un
désastre annoncé elle il pas paradoxal
de miser sur l'extension du haut débit
comme facteur de croissance et
parallèlement suspendre l'accès à
internet qui s'affirme comme un nouveau
service universel coût exorbitant
en conformité au droit européen sur les
libertés fondamentales nombreux
problèmes techniques non résolus dérive
une surveillance généralisée
incompatible avec le modèle démocratique
il est vraiment difficile d'adhérer à un
projet de loi dans l'impact économique
sur la filière culturelle sera marginal
de plus comment ne pas s'opposer à un
texte qui bafoue les principes mêmes de
la justice la plus élémentaire
l'absence de cadre judiciaire de
procédure contradictoire dès les
premières étapes de la riposte graduée
non respect de la présomption
d'innocence
les multiples ruptures d'égalité devant
la loi sont autant d'atteintes aux
droits
et comme si cela ne suffisait pas ce
texte portent également atteinte aux
libertés individuelles car la suspension
de l'abonnement au net revient à une
véritable mise en quarantaine
vu la prégnance de l'électronique
aujourd'hui dans tous les actes de la
vie le plus on sait d'avancé que
l'identification des contrevenants sera
complexe et fastidieuse et que de
nombreux internautes pourront être
sanctionné à tort la riposte graduée est
une véritable machine à produire des
injustices et du contentieux
c'est d'autant plus grave que les droits
de la défense sont amoindris dans la vie
réelle la loi hadopi ne s'attaquera de
fait aux plus novices qui ne savent pas
masquer leur adresse ip
alors que alors même que les véritables
délinquants seront épargnés car ils
disposent de la connaissance
technologique des moyens d'échapper à la
surveillance
le plus curieux c'est que les
internautes ne seront pas sanctionnés
pour téléchargement idéal mais pour
défaut de sécurisation de leur connexion
internet
la plupart d'entre eux l'ignorent encore
il ya un réel manque d'information et de
pédagogie
de plus ces dispositifs de sécurisation
sont complexes et loin d'être
infaillible ce sont les internautes qui
maîtrise le moins l'outil informatique
qui seront pénalisés
est-ce bien juste de surcroît rien ne
garantit que la riposte graduée combine
nos concitoyens acheté plus de dix coups
de musique en ligne
qu'ont fait les industriels ces
dernières années pour améliorer leurs
offres légales en ligne
excepté l'abandon progressif des drm qui
la crise est pourtant réclamée à cor et
à cri ils n'ont guère répondu aux
attentes du public
or nos concitoyens se plaignent à juste
titre de l'insuffisance des offres
légales en ligne car les catalogues sont
limitées les inédits ou les documents
épuisé introuvable et surtout les prix
trop élevé si le chiffre d'affaires des
majors en paix
est en berne elles en sont les premiers
responsables car elles n'ont pris aucune
mesure pour adapter l'offre à la demande
ce qui est pourtant le b à ba de la
réussite commerciale certes une offre
aussi modique soit elle restera toujours
plus cher qu'une offre gratuite mais il
n'est pas juste de faire porter la seule
gratuité du net
les difficultés culturelles comme le dit
le manager d'un des plus grands groupes
mondiaux
la musique gratuite a une vraie valeur
économique la valeur de la gratuité loin
d'être égal à zéro car elle permet de
fidéliser le public de vente des places
de concerts des bonus etc
d'ailleurs je remarque que le film le
plus téléchargé bienvenue chez les
ch'tis est aussi celui qui a battu tous
les records d'entrées en salles on ne
paie n'y aurait que les internautes sont
souvent les plus gros acheteurs et qui
ne souhaitent pas léser les artistes
qu'ils apprécient même le président de
la république considère que l'entrée
payante des musées par exemple
constituer un frein à la fréquentation
des jeunes dont le budget particulier
contre 1 il a voulu il a instauré la
gratuité pour les moins de 25 ans dont
il attend un gain que les jeunes
continuent à fréquenter les musées tout
au long de leur vie
même problématique pour l'instauration
d'un abonnement gratuit à un journal de
leur choix tous les jeunes à celle âgée
de 18 ans le but est d'encourager
lecture et donc l'achat de la presse
écrite
à cet égard je dois dire reconnaître que
la création d'un statut d'éditeur en
ligne est une évolution indispensable
pour permettre de répondre au défi du
multimédia aux attentes des lecteurs
pour autant il faudra répondre aux
inquiétudes des auteurs photographes et
les journalistes concernant les
conséquences de cette nouvelle
législation les industries culturelles
s'obstine à camper pour leur part sur le
modèle pourtant obsolète de la vente à
la copie il est pourtant possible de
développer une offre légale attractive
avec des produits à forte valeur ajoutée
que le public aurait à nouveau envie de
payer
elle pourrait par exemple offrir de
vrais services sur internet un son de
bonne qualité les paroles des chansons
des accusés vite et l'exhaustivité les
catalogues et des prix enfin abordable
d'autant que les coûts de production et
de distribution sont devenu dérisoire
avec la numérisation aujourd'hui la
tendance est au développement des offres
d'écouté à la demande pour ne pas
reprendre l'anglicisme
streaming gratuite comment la radio est
financé par la publicité et ce en toute
légalité puisque ses services ont signé
avec des maisons de disques d accord sur
le partage des revenus publicitaires
avec les ayants droit
ces nouveaux sites qui permettent la
consultation en ligne de musique ou
d'image sans copie de fichiers et qui
sont plébiscités par un public de plus
en plus larges constituent de nouvelles
alternatives au téléchargement illégal
le passage d'une logique de stockage à
une logique de flux s'affirme y compris
pour la vidéo la demande et ce phénomène
se développe avec la généralisation
d'internet mobile à haut débit les
usages évoluent très vite
le streaming est en vogue actuellement
quels seront les pratiques de demain et
d'après demain et au lieu d'anticiper ce
texte de loi persiste contre tout bon
sens apprendre toujours plus de retard
c'est particulier préjudiciable pour la
création les artistes car il passe
complètement à côté de la vraie question
de fond quel adaptation du droit
d'auteur et des droits voisins à l'ère
numérique
selon plus regrettable que les grandes
entreprises après s'est emparée des
tuyaux s'accapare maintenant les
contenus tout en expropriant de plus en
plus les artistes de leurs droits elles
n'ont de cesse de transformer
l'immatériel un actif financier et
rentable s il est primordial de faire
respecter la propriété intellectuelle
cela peut se faire sans opposer les
artistes à leur public
n'oublions pas que le droit d'auteur a
été initialement créé pour protéger
l'artiste du marchand et éviter que
l'esprit des affaires ne s'impose à
faire de l'esprit pour reprendre la
belle formule de mon ami jack ralite
dans le contexte numérique l'auteur n'a
pas changé mais le marchand aujourd'hui
c'est celui qui fait commerce de
contenus électroniques comme les
opérateurs de télécommunications et les
fournisseurs d'accès internet
tous les amendements visant ce qui
contribue enfin la création artistique
dont il tirait dans le petit fils
bénéfices ont été rejetées il a été par
contre préféré de les taxer pour
compenser la suppression de la publicité
sur la télévision publique l'un ministre
vous affirmez vouloir défendre les
auteurs mais alors pourquoi rejeté toute
proposition dont la finalité consiste à
apporter une rémunération nouvelle aux
créateurs
et des financements précieux pour la
production des oeuvres même la
plateforme publique
le téléchargement disant promouvoir les
arts absente de l'offre commerciale dont
la création émergente en particulier n'a
jamais connu assemblant des buses mise
en oeuvre alors que son principe avait
adopté dans le cadre de la loi d'un si
il est vraiment dommage de refuser de
concevoir de nouveaux financements de la
création
alors même que la musique est partout et
qu'elle n'a jamais été aussi écoutée
c'est un atout pour les auteurs et non
une menace
la plupart de nos concitoyens loin de
vouloir attenter à la création manifeste
en permanence leurs intérêts et leurs
besoins d'imaginaire d'émotion de
réflexion malgré la crise financière
sociale économique qui les frappe
durement les salles de spectacles et de
cinéma les musées ou les festivals ne
les amplis spa car la rapporte
d'indispensables repères et redonne du
sens à ce monde qui marche sur la tête
on constate un véritable attachement à
la culture et aux principes
d'émancipation d'ouverture et de liberté
qui lui sont attachés c'est pourquoi on
ne peut que déplorer que la culture la
connaissance la recherche quand les
libertés n'ai jamais été dans les
discours au temps disqualifié maltraité
par le gouvernement et ce texte de loi
participe de cette logique puisqu'il
oppose des artistes public alors que
leurs intérêts respectifs sont
convergentes
le public a besoin des artistes et
réciproquement
la dématérialisation numérique rend
possible de concilier durablement le
droit d'auteur et le droit à la culture
pour tous or ce projet doit renonce à ce
nouveau socialisation que le progrès
technologique et innovation permettent
aujourd'hui
toutefois malgré nos nombreuses réserves
nous prenons acte que le texte de loi
soutenu par de nombreux artistes et
plusieurs organisations représentatives
du monde de la culture
parce que nous respectons cette position
notre groupe confirme son abstention une
abstention toujours combative avec
l'espoir que les artistes s'associent au
public et construisent ensemble un
système de licences inédit audacieux
adapté au numérique est plus juste pour
tous les ayants droit
compte tenu du scepticisme quasi
générale
et de l'échec annoncé de la loi hadopi
il est indispensable pour que la vie que
pour que vive la création de penser à de
nouveaux financements et il ya urgence
car comme le prédisait antonio gramsci
l'ancien se meurt le nouveau ne parvient
pas à voir le jour
et c'est dans ce clair obscur que
surgissent les monstres merci un chèque
collègues non monsieur le président de
la commission des affaires culturelles
et après madame et messieurs président
nous écoutons merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues il y a
des petits miracles dont notre assemblée
peut être fier on disait que le débat
sur ce texte serait difficile
passionné et pourrait même tourner à
l'affrontement dans cette enceinte
nous avons voulu aller au fond des
choses nous sommes écoutés nous ont fait
des pas les uns vers les autres et il
est tout de même très significatif que
notre assemblée est adopté ce texte à
l'unanimité je mets à part bien
évidemment l'abstention du groupe
communiste pourquoi sommes-nous arrivés
à un tel résultat
parce que au delà de nos légitimes
divergences et en étant très conscients
de la difficulté à légiférer dans ce
domaine nous avons tous voulu en bonne
foi protéger la création il y a c'est
incontestable une menace sur la création
la réponse n'est pas facile il fallait
faire comprendre à l'opinion publique
que si le piratage continuer dans les
conditions avec l'ampleur dans laquelle
il se prend il se pratique c'est la
création c'est le sort des créateurs qui
était en jeu et que nous sommes tous
attachés à la protection de la création
je crois que c'était bien le point
fondamental est que c'est ici ce qu'il
faut rappeler alors après bien sûr on
peut diverger
sur la méthode et chercher s interroger
sur les bonnes réponses techniques
nous avons eu ce débat mais nous n'avons
pas les uns et les autres perdu de vue
la nécessité de tenter en bonne foi
d'apporter une réponse une réponse de
deux manières d'une pas en sanctionnant
le piratage abusifs dans le faisant de
manière pédagogique joué une fois de
plus rappelé il ne s'agit pas de
constater et de frapper il s'agit
d'avertir une fois deux fois et 2 ne se
résoudre à la sanction qui touchera les
internautes les plus engagés et engagé
dans une mauvaise habitude en suspendant
leur abonnement donne le faire qu'après
les avoir dûment avertis nous sommes
bien conscients qu'il y a parmi eux une
frange sans doute qu'ils considèrent
très ce que le dob le piratage comme un
sport etc cela il sera difficile mais
avec une pédagogie très adapté de les
faire renoncer ces mauvaises pratiques
mais nous pensons que pour la grande
majorité il s'agit d'une tentation qui
se trouvera remise en cause à partir du
moment où les messages d'alert auront
été envoyées et voilà ce que nous
espérons c'est très clair mais il ne
s'agissait pas seulement
et je voudrais dire un mot si je me
permettais sur ce effectivement ce que
l'on entend sur la double peine il
s'agit comme l'a bien dit notre
rapporteur comme certains intervenants
lors expliquer ici de faire en sorte
qu'une faute constatée ne se trouve pas
en définitive entraîné éventuellement
une revendication légitime du
fournisseur d'accès à l'égard de l'état
ça n'est pas le fournisseur d'accès qui
a supporté les conséquences d'un
comportement fautif et ça n'est pas non
plus à l'état ce serait quand même le
comble d'avoir à payer pour la faute qui
aura été commise par un
pirates du net mais nous ne pouvions pas
en reste et assez qu'on dit c'est à ces
considérations un texte équilibré c'est
un texte qui met aussi un terme à des
atermoiements qui avait été dénoncée
lors notre débat ici au mois d'octobre
sur ce texte et qui faisaient que
l'offre légale était mise dans le public
souvent beaucoup trop tard voilà
pourquoi nous sommes ralliés à cette
norme qui nous paraît effectivement
juste d'inscrire dans la loi et que dire
que quatre mois paraît un délai tout à
fait raisonnable sur ce point il n'y a
pas on le voit bien il n'y a pas eu de
notre part une volonté de s'en prendre
aux internautes ce n'est pas un texte
anti internautes
c'est un texte raisonnable portant sur
la création et la protection de la
création
dernier point on a pu évoquer
s'interroger pour savoir si cette loi
sera applicable et pour savoir aussi si
cette loi sera pérenne
nous savons bien que les technologies
évoluent que la législation ne peut pas
ne pas évoluer quand les technologies
évoluent par conséquent nous aurons
sûrement un moment ou un autre à nous
reposer la question de l'efficacité de
ce texte de son évolution
éventuellement mais ça c'est la vie ça
n'est pas parce que les technologies
peuvent évoluer que les comportements
peuvent évoluer
nous ne devions pas légiférer maintenant
ils étaient en effet urgent de légiférer
nous arrivons madame la ministre à un
relatif consensus sur ce texte
je ne peux que m'en réjouir et souhaiter
au sénat d'être le lieu où les débats se
font dans le respect dans la comparaison
est avec la recherche toujours du
consensus dans le respect bien
évidemment de nos différentes approches
merci merci et ce président madame la
ministre
monsieur monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires culturelles je crois que le
président legendre vient de le rappeler
c'est vrai que c'est une cette loi telle
qu'elle est très attendu ayez eu c'est
vrai une mobilisation vraiment très
forte du monde de culturel du monde
artistique
les des mille signataires un effet de la
palle huld qui ont été adressées les les
37 cinéaste vraiment de premier plan et
personnalités de premier plan qui se
sont également manifestés au plan
européen
l'association impala qui regroupe quatre
mille label indépendant et je crois que
c'est important de montrer que cette loi
n'était pas celle des majeurs comme on a
pu l'entendre ici et là mais qu'elle
était surtout celle en fait de cette
multitude de petites entreprises
indépendantes à 99% au secteur de la
musique avec des entreprises de moins de
20 salariés qui attendaient en effet
avec beaucoup d'impatience qu'il y a de
nouveau un un cadre quelque chose soit
fait pour empêcher ce téléchargement
dans la firme dans la illégales dont la
france est championne du monde du fait
d'ailleurs de la capacité technologique
de cela on peut être peut être fier de
la première chose mais évidemment fier
de la seconde c'est donc une je crois
une loi très attendue c'est vrai que la
particularité c'était qu'elle était issu
d'accords interprofessionnels ce qui
était une différence importante par
rapport aux précédentes lois sur le
droit d'auteur
il ya vu un effet d des mois de
négociations et au fond l'économie cette
économie du projet cette idée d'une loi
pédagogique avec au fond deux grands
volets l'offre légale d'un côté de
développer et puis un processus très
pédagogique cela a été rappelé qui vise
à avertir à provoquer une prise de
conscience avec un effet l'état de la
lettre recommandée qui est adressé à
d'abonnés ce qui met en jeu la
responsabilité parentale chose normale
quand même et enfin après coup une
finalement une suspension d'accès
internet mais elle même discuté entre le
contrevenant et la haute autorité tout
cela finalement c'est un système qui a
été imaginé au départ par les
professionnels
y compris les fournisseurs d'accès à
internet ce qui garantit d'ailleurs sa
faisabilité et qui a paru je crois très
équilibré je remercie vraiment
profondément le bien sûr les rapporteur
michel thiollière catherine morin
desailly le président le sombre tout la
commission des affaires culturelles la
commission aux affaires économiques
aussi tous ceux qui se sont mobilisés
qui ont enrichi cette loi au fil de
débats qui ont été particulièrement
fructueux en effet sera je crois que
l'apport du sénat était très
considérable il y avait vraiment de
voler dans la loi effectivement c'était
le processus pédagogique aboutissant in
fine et à une sanction mais il y avait
aussi le développement de l'offre légale
et il est évident que le sénat joue un
rôle tout à fait crucial dans la
suppression des drm cet été je crois
très important dans le secteur musical
c'est plus qu'un signal c'est vraiment
le paysage de la musique qui change dans
la chronologie des médias on sait qu'ils
avaient des réticences très fortes la
part des exploitants notamment et je
crois que très importante tout ce qui a
été fait dans le sens d'un
raccourcissement de la chronologie des
médias le sénat a aussi apporté je crois
s'est mobilisée dans le sens davantage
d'indépendance en effet de cette haute
autorité avec l'élection l'élection du
l'élection du président je crois que
c'est important
des éléments aussi comme le
référencement la labellisation fonds
pour ceux qui en feront la demande
des sites qui pratique de téléchargement
légal va aussi dans le bon sens il
s'agit de valoriser de visibiliser cette
offre légale dont nous souhaitons tous
qu'elle monte en puissance qui est
d'ailleurs le cas depuis haut depuis la
dernière pilsen a au cours de sa
dernière année
je me réjouis des positions qui ont été
prises à l'effet sur la le paiement par
rapport à de la suspension sur le fath
de qui avait été introduite ensuite plus
tard à l'assemblée de d'être remboursé
finalement delà de la bonne non pendant
le temps qu'on était suspendu moi je
partage tout à fait je l'avais dit
l'analyse selon laquelle effectivement
si l'on achète une voiture là d'être est
évidemment où la personne qui vous a
vendu les voitures ne voit pas tout à
coup le retour d'être est interrompue
parce que vous avez fait je ne sais quoi
sur la route donc je crois que c'était
une c'était une vision qui me
paraissaient inexactes qui aurait été
d'ailleurs injuste je pense
juridiquement a juste et je crois que le
sénat l'avait vraiment porter ils y
allaient aussi je voudrais aussi relancé
sur le tout ce qui est fait dans le sens
de la pédagogie catherine morin desailly
l'a rappelé est important en effet que
les jeunes soient finalement et
notamment dans le dans le cadre fonds
scolaire alerté qui est des messages qui
passe je pense que il faut pas du tout
partir du principe que les jeunes sont
absolument incapables de comprendre
qu'il y a des intérêts qui l'a d'aidé
destinée d'artistes de créateurs qui
sont en jeu je pense que l'on peut tout
à fait à tout à fait exposer des règles
du jeu moi je pense même que en fait il
attendait que je crois qu'on peut très
bien assumé que nous sommes un pays de
grande tradition culturelle qui défend
justement avec force le droit d auteur
il est vrai que c'est la loi création
internet est venu enfin est venue
d'abord au céda ensuite au fond il ya eu
des états généraux de la presse quand
trouver leurs conclusions après et
c'était l'opportunité d'inclure un très
vieux très bien une présence yens
question quels droits d'auteur des
journalistes et le statut d éditeur en
ligne qui permettait en effet de
sécuriser juridiquement le statut d
éditeur et d'affirmer un effet le
principe des droits d'auteur sur le
point particulier qui a fait débat c'est
à dire sur le fait que les
collaborations journaliste entreprises
de presse soient réputés porter sur
l'ensemble des supports savait pas fait
l'objet en effet de ce qu'on appelait le
blanc et c'est pourquoi moi je nous
avions pris au gouvernement une position
de sagesse en disant que c'était plutôt
du ressort des discussions en
l'entreprise plutôt que de la loi bon en
effet serge lagauche a souligné sa
réticence à l'effet sur ce point
finalement c'est un point qui est passé
dans la loi mais je crois qu'en tout cas
d'une manière générale il est il était
intéressant que cette loi création et
internet justement sur les droits
d'auteur porte enfin ce statut de leader
en ligne qui leur permet notamment
d'ailleurs de bénéficier des mêmes
conditions fiscales que l'ensemble des
désirs des idéaux de presse et je crois
qu'on a on a bien avancé
donc au total je crois que c'est un un
cadre juridique c'est une loi modeste
moi je les dis depuis le début on sait
que ça va avancer on sait qu'il ya des
innovations technologiques multiples
bien sûr on pourra toujours trouver des
ruses des parades bien sûr d'eux mêmes
qu'ici vous êtes en voiture vous pouvez
toujours mettre sur votre tableau de
bord un petit appareil qui va vous
signalez radars c'est totalement illégal
c'est pas pour autant qu'on renonce au
code la route voilà on pourra toujours
effectivement contourner mais en
l'espèce on peut toujours aussi affirmé
des valeurs et puis surtout avant dans
l'idée qu' on essaie de créer un cadre
juridique et psychologique qui soit
favorable à la création et est
finalement défavorable à tous et ceux
qui piratage très quotidien qui se
pratique souvent d'ailleurs sans
véritable intention de nuire mais dans
les conséquences finissent par être
absolument massive est absolument
désastreuse
voilà donc je voulais remercier encore
une fois tous ceux qui ont vraiment
enrichi ce débat j'ai le sentiment que
c'est un très bon texte qui est sorti du
sénat d'ailleurs le texte final est
extrêmement proche de celui qui avait
été approuvé par votre haute assemblée
un effet à parler d abstention il vit
d'abord abstention parti comme un parti
communiste mais ensuite
maintenant malgré tout une approbation
massive et c'est un point très important
que de montrer que finalement en france
au delà des clivages et les différences
d'opinion l'on peut quand même se
retrouver sur des principes qui nous
tiennent à coeur
voilà merci
merci à nos munitions général est close
nous passons la discussion du texte
élaboré par la commission paritaire
je vous rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 42 alinéa 12 du règlement le
sénat est appelé à se prononcer avant
l'assemblée nationale il statue par un
seul vote sur l'ensemble du texte sur
mes articles 1 a attrait je ne suis
saisi d'aucun amendements je suis saisi
d'une demande de parole de madame marie
christine blandin sur l'article 10 bis à
chaque collègue vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président l'article 10
bis à n'est pas anodin d'ailleurs il a
été publié par les services du sénat
hier après-midi permettait donc que nous
nous enseigne mission et là ses nerfs et
ni tes dents se féliciter le président
jacques legendre comme madame la
ministre a vraiment été rompu par de
mauvaises pratiques
comment admettre que le gouvernement
dépose un amendement de plusieurs pages
sur le code de la propriété
intellectuelle
véritable cavalier au cours de l' unique
lecture à l'assemblée nationale sans
même avoir eu la décence de soumettre
son texte aux sénateurs comment admettre
sa complicité a laissé modifier le code
du travail par un sous-amendement de
député est ce là l'effet promotion du
parlement vantée par les tenants de la
réforme constitutionnelle
l'urgence puis le contournement du sénat
pour mieux court circuiter le dialogue
social des professions du journalisme
le sous amendement déposé par le député
carte permettra de légaliser à l'avenir
tous les détournements de textes rédigés
ou de photographier au profit d'autres
supports donc internet
ceci peut sembler de bon sens mais aussi
autres titres de presse du même
employeur autres parutions de fréquences
différentes voire tout autre support
commercial pour peu que le patron soit
le même beau marché que certains ont
appelé à la rescousse pour défendre la
daf zee puis l'hadopi doit se retourner
dans sa tombe
notre commission puis le sénat ont été
spoliés du débat c'est le mono cameri
sme et la chambre la plus réactionnaire
n'est pas celle qui en a la réputation
car je rappelle que le sénat avait su
résister à l'exception des droits
d'auteur des photographes dans la loi
davezies exception chef os pmi qui avait
su à l'époque convaincre le gouvernement
et que notre commission avait combattu
avec succès sur un amendement que
j'avais déposé votre contournement de la
haute assemblée est encore plus
scandaleux
après la loi audiovisuelle qui
s'applique avant d'être voté vous
inventez la loi cavaliers qui ne passe
que dans une chambre chers collègues
avez-vous bien vu que derrière l'hadopi
sur laquelle je respecte vos positions
vous allez voter la cession à titre
exclusif des oeuvres qu'elle soit ou non
publier l 132,36 la limitation
arbitraire de la propriété
intellectuelle par la réserve de
non-concurrence titres de presse pour
lequel on a fourni des oeuvres l 121 8
la modification du code du travail
sous-amendement kert une proposition
contraire aux conclusions des états
généraux de la presse
pourtant déjà entachée par la sueur
présence des patrons de presse et un
ordre du jour non débattues
après la concentration des médias
on ajoute l'uniformisation des sources
et la fragilisation des journalistes
cette démocratie là ne convient pas aux
verts merci mme hamelin
y at il d'autres demandes de parole sur
article 1 c'est le président président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je crois qu'à ce moment du débat il faut
quand même rappeler quelques éléments
notre commission se préoccupe depuis
longtemps du problème du droit d'auteur
des journalistes je rappeler qu'il y a
eu des propositions du groupe de travail
de la commission dès 2007 n'était pas à
l'époque le président s'est présenté
valade avait pris l'initiative qui avait
déposé en juin 2008 un amendement signé
également par monsieur louis de broissia
spécialistes au sénat et dans notre
commission de ces problèmes
cet amendement dans la loi lme a été
retiré à l'époque car jugée prématurée
avant les états généraux mais il était
tout à fait conforme à ce que nous
retrouvons maintenant dans la loi donc
je peux regretter moi aussi que nous
n'ayons pas eu l'occasion de débattre
cette question lors du premier examen en
séance ici je partage ce sentiment mais
je dois dire que nous avions
préalablement déjà débattu de ces
questions nous l'avons constaté qu'il y
avait une convergence par rapport aux
positions qu'ils avaient exprimé
préalablement par notre commission je
tenais à le rappeler
merci monsieur le président je ne vois
pas d'autres demandes d'intervention le
vote est réservée conformément à
l'article 42 alinéa douzy règlement je
vais être voit l'ensemble du projet de
loi dans la rédaction résultant des
textes proposés par la commission mixte
paritaire
alors comme explication de vote j'ai une
demande devant la mélo de madame ben
lande
y at il d'autres demandes d'explications
de vote je n'en vois pas la mélo vous
avez la parole
puis madame blandas par la clis et
l'indépendance la présidente 2007 riche
qui n'est pas nouveau puisqu'il se
trouve exprimer notre gratitude et nous
remonter sur la scène une autre femme
égale orange a dit jeudi sa faveur et au
moyen d'engins flottants mais diable de
leurs fonds considérables dans les
études et la vie d'un projet de ce qui a
permis dans la recherche rayon des drm
levant ainsi principaux freins au
déploiement des offres nouvelles
ou encore des oeuvres cinématographiques
pour lequel la cmp
ce que l'on qualifie communément de
piratage recoupe des réalités diverses
il peut s'agir d'actes en série
représentant un véritable commerce et
justifiant une peine lourde comme le
prévoit la loi dadt si il peut aussi
s'agir de copies plus ou moins
occasionnels fait par des jeunes qui se
laissent tenter par la facilité de
l'opération souvent inconscients du tort
qu'ils portent ainsi à des artistes que
pourtant il admire le dispositif proposé
par le projet de loi constitue la
meilleure réponse au piratage car il est
pédagogique et préventif
le système de réponse graduée consistant
à envoyer un message d'avertissement
puis à suspendre l'abonnement sera
dissuasif
il fera prendre conscience de la
nécessité de ne pas télécharger
illégalement des contenus
il ne s'agit pas comme certains ont pu
le dire d'entraver la liberté des
internautes de les ficher ou de procéder
à des films filtrage intempestifs
il s'agit de moraliser l'usagé
d'internet
le débat que nous avons eu au sénat dans
un climat constructif a
incontestablement amélioré et enrichi ce
texte
il a notamment permis de consolider les
attributions de la halle la haute
autorité dite hadopi est de veiller à
son indépendance la situation des
internautes a été sécurisé par une
information renforcée
notre haute assemblée a également
souhaité contribuer
développement de l'offre légale
notamment par la création d'un label le
texte issu de la cmp reprend la plupart
des dispositions votées par le sénat
concernant la suspension de l'accès à
internet
la cmp a choisi de reprendre la
rédaction du sénat qui prévoyait que
l'internaute devra continuer à payer son
abonnement
ceci est tout à fait légitime puisque il
s'agit de respecter les termes d'un
contrat et l'internaute bénéficiaires du
triple-play pourra continuer à avoir
accès au téléphone et à la télévision
comme notre rapporteur l'a très bien dit
en décider autrement aurait fait porter
le coût de la suspension au fournisseur
d'accès et aurait ainsi exposé le texte
un risque d'inconstitutionnalité
notre groupe se réjouit se réjouit qu'un
consensus ait pu être trouvé sur ce
point et sur plusieurs autres
nous sommes parvenus à un juste
équilibre respectant ainsi pleinement le
consensus qui avait été trouvée par les
professionnels de la culture de
l'internet et des télécommunications
le groupe ump votera ce projet de loi
qui répond à une attente forte
n'oublions pas que l'enjeu essentiel qui
nous rassemble tous aujourd'hui quelles
que soient nos convictions c'est la
préservation de la création culturelle à
l'ère du numérique face au pillage des
droits d auteur
je vous remercie merci monsieur
connexion actuelle question de vote la
parole est à mme christine blandin
je ne parle qu'au nom de mes amis
sénateurs vers la création et bien sûr
chère à notre coeur et pour qu'elles
s'épanouissent
nous en sommes d'accord il est
indispensable que les créateurs soient
correctement rémunérés ainsi que leurs
diffuseurs 6
il ne se polit pas les créateurs c'est
pourquoi nous avons regardé avec
attention la création du dispositif
nouveau qu'ils renonçaient aux excès
liberticide de la loi davdsi et nous
nous étions abstenus
dans le climat de sérénité évoqué la
lecture du texte de la cmp reflète le
même ton cependant la loi davdsi reste
en vigueur le nouveau dispositif reste
émaillé d'innovation judiciaire
hasardeuse abandon de la présomption
d'innocence fin de la séparation des
fonctions administratives et judiciaires
comme des promesses de choix cornélien
entre suspicion arbitraire du voisin ou
un faisabilité les utilisateurs de
logiciels libres mais ne peuvent par
exemple jamais faire preuve de
dispositifs de protection mais les héros
de corneille étaient eux
tiraillé par les scrupules formons donc
des voeux pour l'hadopi mais que de
temps perdu pour prendre à bras le corps
de devoir public de soutenir la création
par de réelles financement et par une
vraie prise en main du média internet
pour que ces tuyaux de diffusion
n'échappe pas à l'éthique à commencer
par les opérateurs à commencer par la
fourniture d'une offre légale
à commencer par les coudes des moeurs et
des besoins nouveaux
que de temps perdu chez les
professionnels pour retarder un accord
sur le délai de mise à disposition du
public des oeuvres que de temps perdu
avec les errances de la daf si les
cryptages les incompatibilités les
menaces et soudain c'est l'urgence au
point comme je l'évoquais de court
circuiter le sénat et de spolier les
journalistes et photographes par un
cavalier brutale car si monsieur de
broissia avait travaillé sur le travail
du journaliste et la mise en ligne de
son oeuvre sur internet
ici nous allons beaucoup plus loin nous
autorisons qu'un travail change de titre
en presse écrite
c'est donc avec indignation
particulièrement sur ce dernier motif de
remise en cause profonde de la propriété
intellectuelle à la française par
l'article à 10 bis à pour les
journalistes que les saynètes envers
voteront contre
et nous en appelons à tous les créateurs
et artisans nous partageons les
préoccupations et souvent les luttes
pour qu'il se penche sur le nouveau
contenu du texte qui devient porteur du
sabotage d'une autre profession culturel
au motif de les défendre
merci à chaque collègue il n'y a pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
je me vois l'ensemble du projet de loi
dans la rédaction résultant du texte
proposé par la commission mixte
paritaire qui et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient d'abstention très bien le
sénat a adopté
vous venez de suivre les conclusions de
la commission mixte paritaire sur le
projet de loi création et internet vous
pourrez retrouver cette séance sur notre
site internet www.publicsenat.fr
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt sur public sénat
à